when you guys parted ways I know you
guys are still friends but we're like
I'm gonna bury this [__] I'm a
competitive guy I just but it was also
it was really I don't know who this guy
is so like I can ask that question but
I'm sure he's great it was a scary
moment for me like I went from making 20
or 30 grand a month referring to him to
then making zero and putting it all my
eggs in a new basket or starting a brand
new company this was a scary moment I
jumped off a cliff that was kind that
was 11 months ago and now knowing what
we know now yeah it was a great decision
because
um how big is the new business
all right guys bang bang I've got Nick
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is we're seeing tons and tons
of people who have figured out this hack
on how to build businesses it used to be
you build a product you then you go find
the customers you me many of our friends
are like wait a minute why don't I go
find the customers first then build the
company talk a little bit about your
process you've launched six different
businesses in a short period of time uh
I think you've got a bunch of other
ideas of things that you're going to go
do how are you thinking about like this
new way of building businesses or is it
just an old way that you're kind of
replicating yeah I started talking about
real estate on Twitter got a lot of
followers turns out real estate is very
a business that fuels a lot of sub
businesses it's expensive to buy a
building if you're gonna buy a building
you're gonna pay a slew of other people
lawyers cost like studies
you know a bunch of people to do a lot
of work and
um my business was you know I'm trying
to turn some of my cost centers into
profit centers but yeah I built uh 30
million eyeballs a month on on Twitter
uh newsletter with that's you know a
couple months ago when we were getting
started 30 000 file you know subscribers
now we're up to almost 50 000 folks and
they're people who do real estate deals
and they own small businesses and
they're interested in entrepreneurship
management and um turns out when you
build an audience full of those people
they need a lot of things they need you
know websites they need you know SEO
they need pay-per-click they need
landing pages they need
um cost segregation studies they need
insurance they need a lot of different
stuff so let's talk about the real
estate component first then we'll kind
of go to the other businesses so you
previously had a business I will think
of it as practice you may not think
about that but I always look at like
people who find a decent amount of
success doing something you usually can
trace back somewhere where they learn
some skills learn how to be an operator
yes so talk a little bit about the first
business that you had and how that
fueled kind of what you understood and
when you launched the real estate
business yeah I like to say that I
started in the hardest business in
history the world which is student
pickup and delivery storage we were
literally driving box trucks and towns
picking up 7
000 students a year in a one-week span
during finals week we were storing it in
warehouses we were delivering it we had
you know over 200 part-time employees in
that business we could only be in one
city but we were operating in 12
different locations at 25 different
colleges
and we did that for 10 years a hard
business so people look at me on Twitter
and think oh this guy's just in real
estate you know whatever no I in 2011 I
was driving a cargo van picking up boxes
and um yeah we learned how to hire
people we learned how to manage people
and um made a lot of mistakes and but
you know six seven years into that we
had some serious operational shops we
could hire people we could manage people
we could motivate them and leverage that
to move up I always say business is
about momentum you know you're not gonna
people
so many people want to just get rich
start a business
crank yeah um doesn't work that way so
when you're building that business why
go into the real estate game is it just
like hey that's easier there's less
competition uh I want to do something
different like what is the jump from
like I'm a day-to-day grinding operator
to let me go do real estate I think I
looked at it as hey where are where are
the dumbest people making the best money
there's a lot of dumb people in real
estate but there's also a lot of smart
people well there are a lot of I'm not
I'm not saying that most Real Estate
Investors are dumb I'm saying that you
don't have to be in the top 10 to make a
a killing like in the startup world you
got to be amazing at what you do because
the cream Rises to the top the
competition is incredible I said hey
what industry can we go after here that
the competition you know we just got to
be above average and we can do really
well in our moving company we could see
that it wasn't gonna never it was never
gonna scale into a 10 million business
it was never going to give us the
lifestyle we were on the road we're you
know I was spending a month away from my
families going from college town to
college town you know hauling boxes into
dorm rooms so we said okay what's the
next logical step
um but that sweaty that sweaty startup
had put half million bucks in our bank
account because we had operated for five
years we didn't spend any money and it
turned us into operators so when you got
a little bit of cash and you know how to
operate a business you can tackle real
estate and we looked at hey there's a
self storage business where Mom and Pop
operators don't answer the phone their
units are full and they're making 20 30
40 Grand a month from one location
wow
um that's the business to be in so in
2016 we built a self storage facility
from the ground up opened it in 2017 put
our money in raised money from friends
and family built a building for 2.9
Million Bucks
um learned a ton development was not
really the place to start but we built
it got it up and once we got it running
that's when we hit our stride we're like
wow this is a great business we answer
the phone we do some basic stuff we get
a lot of customers
um fast forward to 2021 that visit that
that building's worth eight million
bucks that we built for 2.9 Million
today it's worth 10 or 11 million
dollars so that one real estate project
that was 20 of our stress 80 of our
stress was over in this moving company
20 of our stress was in self in Self
Storage it generated outsized returns
and so we made a decision to sell the
moving and storage company and do more
real estate so let's talk about the unit
economics of a self storage facility
that you buy first and then we talk
about the development side so what is
like the average size deal that you guys
will go do and how do you find the right
deal so somebody's like oh cool Self
Storage sounds awesome Nick's an idiot I
think I could do better than him where
do they get started well you can because
you find one deal and it can be
life-changing money like we bought a one
little deal in 2018 with our own cash
because we ran out of investor money
really quick like we didn't have any
um not Country Club kid didn't have a
big Network to go raise a bunch of money
which you got to do in real estate so we
did a couple small deals a 472 000 deal
that we did by ourselves with 100 Grand
of our own cash three years later it's
worth a million bucks so like that is
life-changing money so you don't have to
be that smart to do this but yeah you
can buy a small deal for a half a
million dollars lease it up you know
operate it well cut expenses and just
let time do its thing so if you buy
something that's half a million dollars
how many like storage units are coming
with that and what can you charge
normally in one yeah this is a deal of
ours in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania it's 11
000 square feet 66 units okay we get two
phone calls a day at that property our
manager goes out and spends two hours
once a week sweeping out units picking
up trash making sure everything's okay
got a little gate maintenance here and
there you know you wash the buildings
once every two years you pay them every
five years put new gravel down
um pretty low touch though okay and so
when you have 66 units what are you
renting those out for on average the the
property was doing sixty two hundred
dollars a month of Revenue when we
bought it okay so 100 a unit 66 units
um today it's doing about eleven
thousand dollars a month in rent okay so
you basically just double prices uh yeah
marketing getting people in just you
know every time we filled up we raise
the prices and then we get a couple
units open and then we lease them at a
higher rent and do that for a couple
years and all of a sudden your buildings
you know you've doubled tripled net
operating income profit and the
building's worth double and so when you
have one of these properties how much of
the value is derived by the cash flow
that is deriving uh or driving versus
just pure capital appreciation you know
inflation yeah here's the thing about
commercial real estate and why
entrepreneurs and operators love it
um a house you buy a house and it's
worth whatever the appraiser says the
house is worth based on whatever what
the house next door traded for it's all
comps there's no cash flow coming in
from a house do you live in it so
whatever the house traded for that's
what it's worth so over time houses
start trading for more money
neighborhoods and it just naturally goes
up or goes down commercial real estate
is valued based on how much money it
makes so
a you know it's called a cap rate so a
percent return on on overall spend is
what it's worth so if you can make the
profit go up you can physically make the
value of the building goal yeah because
much more valuable okay as you're doing
this uh you're not doing it by yourself
right you guys have built this entire
team of I think like 45 people or so
talk about what are those people doing
somebody here is like oh you own real
estate you have 45 people yeah uh but
they're not actually physically going
every day and you know sitting there as
a receptionist and taking orders or
anything like that what are these people
doing people when you hear people talk
about real estate they think passive
they think hey I'm going to get checks
into my mailbox real estate is not
passive at all if you do it well
um we operate our own properties meaning
when the phone rings our team answers it
when somebody doesn't pay their rent we
call them when somebody abandons their
stuff we have to auction it off we gotta
do property improvements change signs do
the gravel have all the contractors come
in we have a Construction Division and
then we have an entire Finance team that
underwrites and goes out to try to
acquire properties so yeah our team now
45 people we have 1.9 million square
feet of storage 63 properties
um we have an Acquisitions arm
three three folks who are full-time
trying to find deals to buy two folks
who are underwriting deals meaning
figuring out what they're worth our CFO
then offers on this these properties we
have investor relations uh employee who
deals with our 280 active investors who
have you know given bolt storage 40
million dollars
um and then you transfer over okay we've
bought a building then it goes into
property Improvement their jobs the
signage painting the buildings getting
it all cleaned up getting all the units
ready to rent then we have a team of
four folks Who oversee all the vendors
and contractors that we have on the site
so when I say 45 employees that doesn't
account the plow guy the lawn care all
this
um then you have uh the call center
customer service that's eight full-time
employees you got collections you got
auctions property improvements and
construction which is another four folks
who are building about
3.5 million dollars worth of expansion
on properties that we already own okay
and so as you're going through this do
you change the names of the properties
that you guys end up acquiring or do you
just leave them whatever you know Joe
Blows we brand Them All Storage okay and
what is the kind of pros and cons of
doing that uh our domain Authority is
great our SEO is great our you know the
standard procedure of answering the
phone hey this is Bolt storage building
a brand
um yep it's it's ideal over you know
operating it as a you raised 40 million
what do you think everything's worth now
we raised 40 million dollars put in
another five or six of our own cash
bought a hundred million dollars worth
of storage
um before interest rates started going
nuts I mean
right now with
today's revenue and operating income and
the old cap rates 180 190 million
dollars more realistically if we had to
sell right now 140 150 million dollars
um but yeah it's been three four three
four acts on the equity Capital that you
guys were able to it's been it's been a
great well we've raised 40 and we got
yeah between another 40 and 80 more of
equity so yeah two to three x Equity
okay and so when you look at this
business
um why just stay in Self Storage why not
go into other markets it's just a focus
thing is it
um hey we actually don't think we have
an advantage somewhere else is it the
people that are trying to sell those or
lost their minds and they think it's
worth more yeah and the last year has
been very hard when I came on I spoke to
you last time you saw that fire in my
eyes I was like let's go buy a ton of
storage I think I told you that I was
going to buy 100 million dollars worth
of storage in 2022 we bought 38 million
dollars of storage and we were devoting
way more resources way more energy way
more time the business got harder rates
started going up and sellers aren't
going to take discounts now but our
returns go down when interest rates go
up the returns go down on the cash value
put into work in these businesses you
mean that Jerome Powell when he said he
was going to destroy consumer demand he
actually ended up destroying investor
demand he the investors yeah investor
demand investor returns uh the real
estate business got really hard and um
luckily I have a guy on my team Kevin
who
um super disciplined and I was like hey
let's buy these buildings and he's like
hey Jerome Pal's telling us he's going
to raise interest rates three percent
this is not a good buy looking back on
all those deals now he was right I was
chomping at the bid I'm the go go guy I
had some very disciplined people on my
team who kept us from buying too much
storage when how do you structure the
debt is it floating rate stuff is it
fixed rate how long do you it was
floating it was floating uh we got
burned yeah you know because I'm working
on the promote the way all this stuff
works is there's a preferred return that
I give investors for seven percent
annually goes the investors I get paid a
chunk over that so if we're doing 10 12
cash on cash a year I'm getting paid I'm
in the promote well when interest rates
go up three percent that's an extra 2
million bucks a year of debt service
that ate into almost our entire promote
and now are making pref so
um yeah we locked the rates at five and
a quarter five and three quarter between
five and a quarter and five and three
quarters depending on the properties
they're all in great shape we just need
to let time do its thing and yeah you
know let rates come back down we don't
over time we'll least up to buildings
and you know net operating income is
continuing to grow so we're not at risk
of losing any property in any of our
properties but it's a it's not an easy
time to be a real estate investor right
now there's a lot of chaos that people
don't see going on in the real estate
business they had floating rate debt and
more often it's it's loan maturities
when you buy a house you have a 30-year
fixed loan commercial real estate
average loan term is five years and a
lot of it's on three-year Bridge debt
and when that three years is up it's
called a balloon payment you have to
refinance with somebody else you got to
go find some new debt
scramble is on right now from deals that
were bought in 2020 that their debt is
now maturing and the bank's saying hey
we don't want this loan anymore you
gotta go find debt somewhere else and so
the people in the business right now are
seeing a lot of chaos so as you think
about that portion of what you do how
much of the time are you spending a week
on real estate uh in the growth phase
building out this team I was I was
grinding 2021 our team went from six
people to 38 and in 2022 we added
another 10 and then we had to lay off a
couple people last year but I was
working 60 hours a week in the real
estate business in 2021
um today I'm doing three hours a week
because my team is really good eh and B
um it's my job to determine whether or
not we're going to buy a property based
on the purchase price and we're just not
close yeah so okay so you've got the
real estate and you continue to grow
that most people would be like this is
amazing I'm gonna go to the golf course
I'll see you guys later thank you so
much uh you're not like that you're like
okay I'm gonna go start like a gazillion
other businesses
um the cost segregate segregation study
been this I think it's an interesting
one to kind of highlight what you guys
are doing so talk through like who came
up with this idea how do you kind of put
it together and is it something where
like you are literally saying hey I'm
paying this why don't I just create a
business for other people or is there
some more kind of sophisticated I think
we've got to back up to Shepard first
because this is what opened my mind to
this distribution model that you and I
are both on to and several other
influencers are doing a guy named
Marshall Haas started a company called
support Shepherd I was a customer of
theirs in early 2021 and he got me three
Filipino employees for customer service
and call center work I interviewed them
and I hired all three on the spot
because it just blew my mind that you
can get this this quality of person for
ten thousand dollars a year less than a
thousand dollars a month I can hire
somebody who can do this
um and then I went to Marshall I was
like hey man I want to promote Shepard
can you give me a little referral cut if
I tweet about the business
that was in April of 2021 the company
was doing about 40 Grand a month of
Revenue um
yeah they were delivering a lot of
badass talent to business owners in the
service was unbelievable and I'm like
hey I could I could sell the [__] out of
this like let's do something
you fast forward a year of me tweeting
and promoting Shepard online
and the business had 7x in size 7x seven
times larger
this is when I went this is when the
light bulb starts going off in my
entrepreneur head is like hey
um this is a good business I want to own
part of it like Marshall let's make a
deal where you cut me in and I said hey
I want to own 20 20 of Shepard he's like
what are you talking about you're
getting a 15 cut on commission you just
want me to give you an equity slice and
it was a negotiation back and forth and
I was like Marshall I'm gonna go
start a similar company and I know it's
a hard business and it would have been a
you know brain damage I'm not sure if I
would have fully went through with it
but were you bluffing
I I don't know I have to be honest yeah
part of me says No but building that
company like he's got 120 employees and
yeah a ton of hard it's an agency it's a
very hard business so he's he finally we
made a deal where I'm a 15 Equity owner
this is April of last year and he just
gave you the equity gave me the equity
in exchange for which is already done my
distribution in the future and for what
I had done okay and
you know what's the trick what of the
growth is attributable to me and my
Twitter audience I don't know
um but it didn't hurt it didn't hurt I
think it was a good deal for him and I
know it was a good deal for me fast
forward to today and my 15 Equity slog
and Shepard is 50 plus thousand dollars
a month to me that's massive this is a
business worth almost 20 million dollars
um some paid ads a lot of word of mouth
because it's a badass service but a lot
of it was my distribution so light
bulb's starting to go off in my head
when I made this deal with Marshall the
company's going really well
then I had another guy that was doing
cost segregation things which a cost
segregation study is an engineered
report that basically when you buy a
piece of real estate it it lays out your
depreciation schedule for the IRS
um Google segregation I don't know if
you want me to explain it anymore but
basically if uh you buy a piece of real
estate you can depreciate things but you
can actually accelerate some of it
depending on what it is so maybe the
windows get higher depreciation then
let's say the door handles or whatever
and uh this business and other
businesses like it go through and
literally lay out every single thing in
the piece of real estate that you can
accelerate or things that you won't be
able to excel yeah and if you buy a lot
of real estate which I did in 2021 you
can get massive accelerated depreciation
and carry forward a multiple
seven-figure loss me personally on my
personal tax return a multiple seven
figure loss so funneling my small
business income into real estate buying
that real estate getting the
depreciation
again 2023 multiple seven figures of
personal income last year zero dollars
of federal taxes for me because it's all
deferred like I will pay it recapture it
later but cost segregation is working
miracles in what I do
um cost segregation guy on Twitter
um reached out to me we made a very
similar deal a year earlier
um and it was going really well his
business was doing about 350 Grand a
year when we started and then and now
it's about 1.2 million eight or nine
months in sending him a ton of cost
segregation business and I went to him
and said hey man I need to own like 40
of your company or I'm gonna go start my
own business
um and he said no Nick like I don't I
don't necessarily want to grow I got a
ton of clients this has been an amazing
relationship you know you're you've been
a blessing for me and obviously
um this has been a great deal for me my
company's large enough the guy was
making almost half million dollars a
year at this point so we parted ways
shook hands still very good friends to
this day
a week later me and Mitchell Baldridge
my CPA who his internal office had done
100 plus cost sake studies he's one of
the smartest guys I know his wife is an
ex-kpmg consultant a killer
um she was kind of looking for her next
gig her kids were you know old enough
and she was ready to go uh we formed Ari
Costa a cost segregation study service
when you guys parted ways I know you
guys are still friends but we're like
I'm gonna bury this [__] I'm a
competitive guy I just but it was also
it was really I don't know who this guy
is so like I can ask that question but
I'm sure he's great it was a scary
moment for me yeah like I went from
making 20 or 30 grand a month referring
to him to then making zero and putting
all my eggs in a new basket of starting
a brand new company this was a scary
moment I jumped off a cliff
that was 11 months ago and now knowing
what we know now yeah it was a great
decision because
um how big is the new business Ari
costech did 250 Grand of Revenue last
month okay we have 23 employees
um it's a business that's it's a 10
million dollar company in 11 months okay
and is it 10 million dollars on its way
to 12 or is it like 10 million on its
way to 50. to 50. yeah it's going to be
a big business okay and most of that is
coming off of like Twitter
that's the only thing that we've done so
far for distribution yeah yeah we're
gonna open up to some new marketing some
you know in outside sales we're going to
grow the company the traditional way but
yeah we've gotten from zero to over 700
cost segregation studies completed in
less than a year and we've track down a
ton of the talents through Shepard yeah
you know we've done a hired a lot
through Twitter my distribution network
has been fuel but the team is amazing
like Mitchell's a genius and so is his
wife so there's one other piece to this
though that I think people are like okay
look at these [__] guys they're just
tweeting and they're making all this
money like this is [__] but there is
some Nuance to what you guys did because
with the cost segregation business it
used to be that you would call a person
would drive to your physical location
right they would walk around with like
the little clipboard take a bunch of
notes go back to their office on their
paper [__] do a bunch of stuff and
then send you a report and you're like
oh thank you very much here's your money
you all were like well screw cars screw
paper screw all this stuff like if I
understand it correctly you guys are
literally just having the real estate
owner on like FaceTime yeah
we have several different things that we
can do and none of them are
groundbreaking Evolution okay world
changing you know new idea stuff we have
Engineers that have been civil engineers
and mechanical engineers for a long time
in column and in the states all over the
place but remote
um we have a FaceTime method where hey
you buy a property get on with one of
our reps and walk around and he or she
will literally point out and we'll take
screenshots and we'll do this entire
documentation process in 45 minutes I
don't need to fly there so we can
deliver a Costa 40 cheaper and three
times as fast as our competitors and
that's the real magic yes so like the
reason why I call that out is I think
that a lot of folks uh are like oh I
don't have distributions I can't build a
business but it's not just distribution
like distribution is the gas that gets
poured onto a fire but really the
benefit that you guys did is just like
any other business uh you have innovated
whether it is a technological innovation
or just a business model Innovation you
can now do this anywhere in the world
you're able to do it remotely and you're
able to do it cheaper and faster than
everyone else is when you look at that
it's like wait a second you're actually
providing a better service which then
when you put the distribution and kind
of the spotlight on it then people like
oh no [__] I want to use them versus
someone else so it's like funny thing
about this I've never met anybody in the
company in person uh we have one of our
head Engineers driving down from Tampa
we're in Miami for off-site for Ari
Costa right now first time you read
three folks flew in from Houston we got
two guys coming in from Colombia the
country in Latin America one more
driving down from Tampa I mean these are
folks I've never met before that are are
building a company and and crushing it
in real time when you think of that
business you said you know it's 10 on
its way to 50. uh how much of the cash
are you guys pulling out versus
reinvesting and the numbers itself don't
matter as much as like how you guys are
thinking about each one of these
businesses because there's cash where a
lot of tech startups like I know
Founder's been working on their cover
for 10 years they've been getting a
salary and that's it right and so when
you drive cash it actually introduces a
new decision framework that you have to
have so uh Coke Industries famously you
know the two brothers uh I think it was
three but now it's two uh sat down and
said hey look uh we're gonna put 90 back
into the business and we're never gonna
take out more than 10 percent some
people say no actually when I put a
dollar in there I can't generate as much
return on it as I can if I go and I take
it out and I put it somewhere else how
have you guys thought about that across
some of these businesses yeah um
it's a it's a tricky balance we're
investing a ton because we've hired fast
and we're building software and we're
building a lot of systems
um but yeah it's a it's a it's going to
be a cash flowing business and we're
pulling we're pulling it out so there's
nothing like we're looking at hey what
can we spend this money on inside the
company and it's at a certain point it's
like hey we have the people we need
we're building the software we need and
we're making these big Investments but
uh we might as well send a hundred
thousand dollar distribution because the
money's piling up all right so there's
like I'm gonna call them real estate
adjacent businesses that you guys are
building and then you get on Twitter one
day and you're like all right [__] it
I'm just going to do a landing page
business and I was like Nick has lost
his mind like next time this guy's gonna
be like I've got a bowling alley I've
got this like talk about daycares and
like all kinds of stuff right and so
like real estate adjacent businesses I
think people are like okay got it he's
got a bunch of real estate he knows what
a good service or product looks like he
knows what the cost structures are like
he probably actually knows people who
are good at doing this already we gotta
talk about Titan risk because I think
that could be bigger what is that very
costly it's a it's a Property and
Casualty Insurance business so if you
buy a piece of property you need
insurance the standard model of the
business is a producer somebody who
sells insurance goes to a golf course
joins the country club and goes and
talks to the Real Estate Investors in
the country club gets their policies
makes it to where he's making two or
three 300 Grand a year and then just
plays golf the rest of his life I mean
that sounds cool that's what the
business is though
um when you take when you solve for
distribution you can find folks who are
used to the old school Consulting models
where we're going to work really hard to
service these policies a lot
um so yeah we're flipping the property
Casualty Insurance business on its head
with Titan risk my business partner Dan
is actually CEO of that company and he's
the best operator I've ever met we
partnered with and look all these things
I'm doing are opportunistic if I find
the right operator with the right skill
set and I can convince them to come on
my team that's what I'm gonna hop on
something that's when we talk about web
run Labs but yeah I mean last month was
renewal for both stores we had to renew
our policy 380 Grand is what the quote
came back at Titan risk 280 Grand in our
umbrella why can you do that we worked
it like we we just like hey uh the
renewal's coming our Brokers always just
sent us the renewal sorry guys Insurance
went up this year we're like uh-huh we
are now the broker let's work it let's
call all the freaking carriers we got we
got a huge portfolio of 1.9 million
square feet everybody wants our business
let's get after this
and then oh yeah when you work it hard
you can you find good coverage okay so
how much are you putting in to start
these businesses uh We've struck the
check for 50 you know 100 we put 100
Grand in the checking account to start
recasting okay we put 50 Grand of
checking accounts to start Titan risk I
put 20 grand in a checking account to
start web run Labs
um recruitjet was 25 grand
um so you're putting let's call it
somewhere between 20 and 100 Grand
that's right for each one of these uh
which it's like an angel check
essentially but you're the only investor
or only Capital going into 20 to 100
Grand why is it that a tech startup
needs two million or 3 million dollars
to get going versus some of these
businesses only need you know 25 to 100
grand these businesses are operating now
like there's a market there's customers
there's businesses that are making good
money we're not Reinventing the wheel
like yeah we're doing little things to
make it more efficient like the cost of
company but we're not saying hey we're
trying to go out and train a market and
flip an industry on its head I'm very
lucky that people do that because I just
got an Uber across Miami in in two
minutes I'm lucky that there are people
out there changing the world and they
should be handsomely rewarded I'm not
that guy I'm gonna be the guy who
employs a lot of people builds teams and
builds companies that produce cash flow
if Travis will still see if Uber might
have been one minute
I'm just kidding just kidding just
kidding um and so when you look at
something like web run Labs right it now
you to get outside of uh the real estate
adjacent businesses is that just like
hey anywhere that's distribution can
help I'm interested or was there some
sort of strategic thought process for
some of these other businesses so I I'm
really running internet companies like
my real estate is an internet company
Ari Costa is an internet company and
what does an internet company needs it
needs a place where you funnel traffic
it needs a really good form a really
good landing page it needs when somebody
fills a half a form you need to be able
to hit them with email sync which is to
get them back in to fill out the rest of
the form to become a qualified lead you
need a beautiful landing page to be
built I just happen to in my network
have an operator who is one of the best
ux designers that I've ever met
so boom that's where web run Labs came
and if you go to
sell.boltstorage.com or
invest.bullstorage.com those are people
who want to sell their storage
facilities and people who want to invest
in Bolt storage those are both landing
pages built by web run Labs so like
profit centers into and and recast tag
we're building landing pages for them
it's like all this traffic's got to go
somewhere and we need it to be tight
these sales funnels of winning people
get emails where they get emails you
know how important that stuff is so yeah
landing page was a little bit outside of
my zone but every one of my companies is
a customer of LeBron Labs how much does
it cost for a landing page three to five
grand okay there's people who will say
that's really cheap there's people who
say it's really expensive which is it
yeah one of the guys complained on the
Tweet about how expensive I mean it's a
lot of freaking work the company's not
profitable yet we're four months into
building an agency and we can talk about
building these companies in a minute if
we have time but like it's messy
building these businesses requires a lot
of people it requires a copywriter it
requires designer it requires uh the
developer in the back end putting the
elements together a ton of research on
the company a lot of back and forth
working a salesperson doing these things
right and converting leads is worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
these companies and um how do you know
when to hire people full-time versus use
outside contractors early on I was this
my mindset has really shifted on this
early on I was hey uh if we don't need
this let's do it ourselves a little bit
longer
I'm now confident enough in my
distribution and confident enough in my
ability to sell customers that we're
hiring ahead of Revenue in almost all
these businesses we're literally saying
okay we're going to start this company
right now and we need six people we need
two designers we need two ux guys we
need a sales person and we need a
copywriter and we're gonna hire them all
right now and build the team and when
you do it that way you can grow agencies
faster okay so I don't give a [__] about
your companies uh I know that they're
successful I know that they're working
but I also have The Insider perspective
if I know everything that goes into
these businesses so I want to dig into
some of the details that other people
might not know to ask you uh let's start
with the content side there's a bunch of
different platforms are you posting [__]
on Tick Tock are you you know emails
more important like how do you think
about the various platforms and where
you put most of your focus versus maybe
other places where like I could be there
but it's not really worth it yeah I went
to a mastermind in Cabo with saho and
Nathan Barry from convertkit some of
these guys and they opened my mind to
uh just building an organization around
myself and you have done it very well so
in the last three months I've hired a
full-time copywriter who's very good I
hired a uh an operator like a kind of a
holding company operator he's the one
who will set up all the internal
workings of the business get the web
page up like all the emails going to the
right people everything all set up like
a kind of a CEO of my holding company
um a designer that can do my you know
little videos
um copy editor for my newsletter so yeah
the the company on top of the companies
is forming now just because I'm a I'm a
delegator if I have a if I have a job in
one of my companies I'm pissed I still
write all my tweets I recycle a lot of
them with help and I still write my
newsletter every single week my
newsletter is kind of like My Personal
Diary of how I'm thinking about the
world and I'm gonna be really happy that
I wrote that every week
um when I'm when I'm 50 60 years old can
you Outsource the Tweet writing or the
newsletter eventually
like forget it if you want to or not but
is it something where it's so unique and
people will be like no that's not Nick
or is it something that you could train
someone else you could find someone who
writes well something like that if
somebody if you what do you think do you
think I could I don't know I'm not gonna
tell you what I think until you tell me
I don't know I think that's the one
thing my writing that I might not be
able to Outsource I think it's the most
it's the thing that each one of us is so
emotionally connected to but it's
emotionally connected to not because
we're like oh the audience is gonna like
notice because I actually think you can
train someone to do it pretty uh easily
um I've been very surprised at how
people can write in a very similar style
um but I think that it is uh less
effective when you Outsource it because
you just said it's diary it forces you
to organize your thoughts and so when I
think about the things I write actually
I will then later reuse them so I may
write something you know in the first
week of the month and three months later
I'm on a television interview and I pull
something up how do you know that like
because I [__] went researched it and
I wrote it and it's the same thing as
you know they say if you write notes or
whatever you always remember stuff so I
think there's that aspect to it the
second thing is it forces you to collect
your thoughts and like be really
thoughtful and think a little bit deeper
maybe than you would just in
conversation or whatever but then the
third piece of it that's fascinating to
me is like then you put out in the world
and I'm sure you just like I get back
you know hey you're an idiot hey you're
a genius and you're like okay which one
is it right you gotta look at the
feedback you got to understand like oh
actually this person who's being
critical has a good point and yeah I
should incorporate that more this person
who's actually saying I'm a genius like
they're just saying that to everyone
that sends them an email right and so
you almost have to like think through
again not just writing but now you gotta
actually evaluate the feedback to know
what's right what's not I look back and
I look at what I do now inside my
companies the written word is how I do
everything the written word is how I
lead other people the written word
through text messages emails slack
notifications is how I guide my
employees the written word is how I
convince and sell these operators to
come partner with me to build companies
the written word is everything that I do
you said something when you were talking
to Sam on my first million or was a Sean
that interviewed you you said like okay
the the business show that you did every
morning for two hours for two years
okay looking back was it a use was it a
useful you know dollar per hour value of
my time maybe not but the skill that you
built doing that now you can go on CNBC
and argue with the biggest baddest
[__] in the world and you're
gonna hold your own every single time
yeah it's like okay they don't like when
you do that by the way
it's building it's building that skill
set and I can lean back on my writing
I'm going to lean on my writing for
everything that I do the rest of of you
know my time and I was talking to it
goes back to a sports story
a decathlete that I really respect when
I was in the track days we were sitting
on the side of a meeting he had his left
hamstring was all taped up and we were
at like the USA championships he had to
get a certain you know time or score to
to make sure that he had a spot not this
year he was gonna withdrawal but the
next year and some events that he wanted
to do and I was like why are you out
here like limping like are you not in
his and you just had such a positive
attitude and he's like I'm better at 60
percent
than the fourth place guy in America at
100 so I'm gonna be here and I'm gonna
get this done and I just I'm confident
enough that I can limp along and I can
score my 8 900 points and I can do what
I got to do
that stuck with me like if I can do
enough of these interviews with you that
if I come in here sleep deprived I'm
gonna I'm gonna be able to hold my own
you're gonna practice enough the way
that you speak and the way that you you
know do your media that even on your
worst day people won't even notice that
you're off your game same with my
writing my writing is going to be the
skill that I lean back on to do
everything that I want to do in my life
whether it be books teaching giving back
leading people building companies it's
all writing there is
um one of the rules of Twitter is the
stupidest tweets are the most viral
right as we all know so frustrating but
but yeah I mean like literally for those
who don't know kind of what what this
unspoken rule is is like somebody can
sit down and like think of the greatest
tweet ever they can do a whole thread
they can do all this stuff and like it
works
literally you're taking a [__] and you
just fire off a tweet and it goes viral
right uh we I'll give you two examples
so we recently posted something on
Instagram and uh it's an interview with
a guy Jason Lowry from space force and
it's not even me in the video at first
it's my brother he's like what's the
funniest thing about space right and uh
and Jason just goes uh when you look
into space you're actually looking down
right and then it's like me and my
brother's all laughing whatever put it
on Instagram I go to sleep wake up it's
got like 150 000 you know views on it or
something I was like what the hell best
performing video that we've posted in
like probably a year right and so I was
like all right now when I was younger
and less experienced I'd go post 20
Space videos right the next time but
like obviously no it's just an anomaly
whatever okay fine second thing is uh
normally every Saturday we post an
update on the uh kind of the week of
Bitcoin right so I come in here got the
nice camera these guys are all set up
got the lights on you know okay let's do
our [__] thing all right we may even
do a little research God forbid right
and then we're ready to go this past
weekend I got caught in a meeting on
Friday couldn't record it so Saturday
morning woke my ass up grab my phone sat
and you know right on the couch did a
quick video sent it to these guys like
this that's the best we got right if I
can post that [__] double the views
right and you're sitting there and
you're like
now again when I was younger I'd be like
we're only doing phone videos all right
and you realize like some of this
novelty right some of it's the change of
pace some like there's a whole bunch of
different things that go into it and so
like you don't want to mess with the
magic and you kind of just like just go
about it and keep consistently creating
things but also you start to realize
like dude we can't predict this [__]
yeah right there's been interviews I've
done with people I've been like there's
gonna be a grand slam we're gonna do
five million uh uh views on it nothing
like literally 2 000 views you're like
it's not even like okay I thought we're
gonna get five thousand we got 2 000
right it's like no we literally thought
it's gonna be our best and it was our
worst the power went off so far the
fluidity of this stuff is mind-blowing
like how how it moves you can't predict
it and that's why I think it's just
about getting in the game and taking
shots I mean I'm not a high risk kind of
shot guy like a I think almost all these
companies will do some level of success
but you don't know which ones are gonna
go you don't know which operators are
going to be the operators to really take
company the next level it's just about
being in the game and producing and just
doing getting uncomfortable in doing
everyone wants to talk about hiring
employees but that frankly has played
out in my opinion when you're trying to
hire these operators they're like GM
CEOs whatever I've had great success
I've had great failures in doing this
what are you looking for and then what
are the red flags when you're actually
looking at these people
it's
more of an art than a science just like
you said some of the interviews you
think are going to be amazing and they
flop some of the operators that I think
are going to be amazing
they're just okay but some people with
just have that god-given ability to lead
other people
I think it's all communication it's all
writing and it's all leading and putting
together other people if you're good at
your job like I don't necessarily want a
very talented
technician
I need somebody who can make other
people good at their jobs I have a
saying like if you want to make good
money in this world get really good at
your job if you want to earn great money
in this world make other people good at
their jobs and so if you can lead other
people and enable other people and
Empower them and and frankly a lot of it
is just having the having the guts to
delegate delegating is so uncomfortable
because we know that you can do media
the best I know that I can do Self
Storage the best it's really hard to go
up control to other people to do those
things but when you start doing it man
magic magic happens so I'm looking for
people who can delegate I'm looking for
people who can Empower others and you
know make other people good at their
jobs when you're doing interviews are
there any questions or anything that you
really try to kind of get at some of
this stuff
the motivational interview is one of my
favorite things just so that I know in
my opinion it's all about expectations
I'm very good at managing expectations
and that's why I don't piss people off I
don't let people down because I'm going
to tell them like it is I'm not going to
Rose color you know put it through Rose
Colored Glasses so when I'm an interview
and you know you come in and say hey
Nick I want to start a company with you
I'm like all right what's the best case
scenario six months from now um and I'll
uh if they say Okay I want to be making
you know I want to be doing a million
ARR I want to have you know 60 margins I
want to have a team of 30.
um okay well six months from now no
that's six months into building an
agency from the ground up is going to be
that really really frustrating time
where you have your seven employees that
you started with and you're just now
you're just now putting it together to
break through and actually pump on some
marketing and actually grow a company
there's that month two to month six
that's just a grind it's not fun
nobody's having fun The Operators having
bad weeks you know you don't even know
if it works yet you're not sure if it
works you're not sure if it works yet
and then sometimes months six months
seven it can just click and then boom
you got your systems it's firing people
are trained and it's rolling so and then
the five year question is even more
important hey we're in this room right
now and you and I are building this
business and we're five years in and
things are going [__] awesome like
you come in here and you're lit up
you're having the most fun you've ever
had all your career dreams are coming
true
tell me what's going on what's going on
in the company how big is the team what
are you doing day to day who are you
leading and they start to and then I
just shut up and I let them talk to me
about what they see what position they
see themselves in in four or five years
and it's amazing that that will kill 30
or 40 of relationships right there
because I can't deliver what they need
and want
does that make sense it makes a ton of
sense and I guess when you're doing that
you're looking for the right answer or
you're looking for alignment in terms of
what you think the business can do as
well this is this is past the point I
guess if we back up I'm looking I'm look
getting a look in their brain how do
they think about things how do they talk
about things I'm really good at asking
the questions and reading how somebody
thinks it's just a I've hired enough
people now that I have a natural ability
to tell if somebody's got it if they're
an a player if they're 10xer if they can
communicate really well if they're clear
they're concise they can think about
problems the right way so I'm having
conversations I'm interacting with
people and I'm saying okay this person
is an operator they got it like I think
that they have it then it's all about
look for the red flags that might [__]
something up and that's what this is
about so yeah the motivational interview
is hey we're gonna we're gonna paint
this picture and I'm looking for red
flags that means that maybe this is not
going to work
what I don't want that stress man most
time I'm trying to convince people to
leave high paying jobs the guy who's
building web run with me had a 400 000 a
year job and I sold him on coming to
build an agency with me yeah he's gonna
make way more money doing the agency
probably than he will in that other job
you don't think so we haven't made a
dollar yet yeah three months in of
course like if you can swallow the
short-term pain right it it's basically
if he was making 400k doing the same
thing that means somebody else was
making way more than 400k so if he can
just replicate the same business but if
I have a guy like that and I he comes in
and he starts talking to me and I'm all
pump up I'm all like dude we're gonna
get rich like this is gonna be awesome
we got more business than we could ever
hope for like all we gotta do is build
these systems hiring the employees I got
that solved through Shepherd like we got
all these ways that we can do this and
then he gets in the trenches in two
months in he's like Nick this is not
what you told me like this is not the
life like so it's more about hey we can
do this and we can make a lot of money
and we're gonna learn a shitload and
you're going to become a way more
valuable manager delegator operator and
I'm gonna learn a lot and we're gonna
make mistakes and we're going to grow
and it's going to be a journey
we might get rich but it's gonna be
[__] hard you want to talk about
someone's gonna piss people off right I
stopped selling people on doing things
because I know I can convince them to
this point right if I want someone to do
something I can be very convincing the
problem is that they get two weeks four
weeks two months four months whatever
later yep and they're like damn I fell
for it yep right I I I I was uh uh put
under the spell and like it sounded
amazing whatever and so in some way what
you're describing is the same thing of
like if you if you promise everything
and you say it's going to be this great
thing people actually believe it right
and that's why most people who can build
a lot of organizations and things like
that they're very good at selling
whether they realize it or not and so
I've literally said to people that I've
been trying to recruit I am not going to
sell you on this yep go think about it
I'm not going to reach out to you I'm
not gonna do anything you come back to
me if you think this makes sense but
like basically you got to make the
choice because if you're not bought into
this then like I'm gonna trick you
essentially right not me not not in a
fairious way but like I will convince
you to do this and it's just gonna be a
train wreck in the future and I am
surprised at how many people end up
getting it right they trust you well
they just get it right in the sense of
like that also can be people come back
like hey it's not for me yeah and I'm
like why right because I'm just as
interested in why it's not for you as if
it was for you and they'll say like two
or three things and I'm like actually
that's a that makes a ton of sense and
like you shouldn't do this if those are
things you're worried about and so I
recently had a guy who it pissed me off
a little bit
um in that we were convincing him to
draw one of our companies on a Friday
he's like I'm in verbally commits we
spend all day Saturday drawing up all
the papers all the stuff and everything
send it to him he's supposed to sign
Sunday
they'll hear from him now it's afternoon
yep my hey dude like you know and I was
very clear we moved quick right uh
Sunday night
hey what's up
already kind of you know skating on ice
back pedaling a little bit whatever he's
like let's get on the phone on Monday
morning you knew then well he just gets
my phone he said look my heart's not in
it and I said to him by the way don't
tell people you're in and then and be
out but I'd rather you figure this out
now than later and like I actually
walked away respecting this guy right
because I was like look okay cool he's
younger guy you know he he definitely
kind of got caught up a little bit in
the speed of everything or whatever but
like man that's even harder once you've
already like a lot of people will just
be like cool I said I'm in it's like I'm
gonna do it but like I know my heart's
not in it and I'll just like try to you
know brute force it for a couple months
yeah but he had the discipline to just
take a step back I actually don't want
to do this right my heart's not in doing
this specific task I want to do
something else and so I think like it's
all about that alignment or the buy-in
that's really where the magic is and so
you got to be careful because if you're
good at selling right you can probably
convince I learned early I learned early
in my career that if you're really good
at selling the positives you're going to
be stressed out because stress is a gap
stress is a gap between reality and what
you told somebody it's a gap in
expectation whether investors employees
your spouse whatever if you set
expectations here and you're here that's
stress you told somebody you're gonna
arrive at three o'clock and you arrive
at 3 15 that's stress right but if I
tell somebody I'm laughing because Miami
time that's like this whole city
operates on I'll be there Tuesday at 9am
I show up Wednesday at 3 P.M I fit right
in there because you've interviewed me
twice I've been late both times but look
it's because Travis isn't running Uber
the way that I sell the way that I sell
now is being a realist I have the
experience I have the resume people know
that I'm Legit and when I sit here and
tell them that hey this is not all Rosie
what you see on Twitter is not real life
building this business is going to be
hard let's talk about the worst case
scenario let's talk about how you and I
are going to interact in 12 months if
we're going to shut this business down
let's have that discussion right now
they walk away and they're like damn
okay Nick is like either he scared the
[__] out of me this is not for me that's
great I wanted that to happen or he's
like I trust Nick like I I know that
what he's saying is real because he
didn't just talk about the awesome stuff
and it's fun and great to sell with all
the awesome stuff but you know that
creates stress so we talked about
putting capital in initially how do you
know when to stroke another check
because the first check's fun because
optimistic hey we can go build a
business yeah the second third fourth
check that you may have to write
now it's like am I basically just
lighting money on fire because we're
never going to get to the other side
yeah or it's like no I've Got Deep
confidence in this and like I'm
basically just you know getting bridging
us there yeah how do you think about
making additional investments into a
business that might not be at kind of
profitability yet I these businesses are
lean and the operator is a lot of times
compensated on the first chunk of
Revenue meaning like the first 100K of
profit or the first 50k of profit will
go to that person for doing the work the
operations then after that it's an
equity split so a lot of times we're
only burning five ten Grand a month so
we're going to be up we got some Runway
an example of this that I think is
really interesting is I wanted to start
a commercial debt brokerage company okay
meaning hey if you're a big real estate
developer and you're going to go get
loans you need a team of people to
negotiate loans on your behalf you need
somebody who has relationships with the
bank they're going to make sure the
bank's not going to retrade and they
charge you 100 basis points or one
percent of your loan amount to do all
the work for you for your debt it's a
great business for everybody involved
I had a banker that has been working
with bolt storage I have a really close
relationship with him he is a killer
he's been in the banking business for 15
years and he is very very very good at
what he did
I wanted him to be one of my operators
and this is one of my recent failures I
want him to be one of my operators and I
was willing to stroke a big check and
put my money where my mouth is because I
know my audience needs this and I know
him and I know he's great and I know we
can build a team to make money and I
said look I will pay you out of my
pocket I'll sign a contract that says
you're going to get 200 Grand a year for
the next 24 months whether this works or
not I'm going to be paying you this
money
and if it doesn't work I'm going to pay
you the money
and then I told him about the equity I
told him how we're going to split the
company up and it was all fine and dandy
and he just said look Nick I've spent 15
years in the banking business I'm not an
entrepreneur I made 500 Grand last year
I got two kids like I don't need this I
don't need the stress I don't need the
entrepreneurship I hope your business
does really well
and he told me no and that was a tough
you know why right why bro I've been
telling people for years short the
bankers man these dudes they're Bankers
you're right they're Bankers right I
mean that as much as I joke about that
stuff like it is a uh it's a different
DNA right lawyers are the same way
um I can't get my lawyer to start a
business with me either pomp so I have a
concept for 1031 Title Company combined
great freaking business because when you
start 1031 company you are the steward
of the cash they put 10 million dollars
in an account that you can go put in
treasuries and you get the money from
the treasury like 90 days or something
right yeah it's a business that if you
get a couple 1031s going it's a couple
hundred thousand dollar a year business
he's like
so uh I'll give you a couple these are
all free gems for people from years of
bashing my head against the wall which
I'm sure you guys for these two I tried
to buy a law firm in 2000 and early 2019
I because I was sitting there and uh
I've been doing a bunch of venture
investing and I was like these guys are
just cleaning up great business I was
watching the checks yeah but I was
watching the checks we were written from
the asset management firms and I'm like
dude these guys are cleaning up and then
through the bear Market of crypto I was
like yo these guys are still cleaning up
like literally they may make more money
than some of these companies are gonna
end up making and so I gotta own one of
these these they make money in Good
Times bad times whatever and so uh I
didn't know if you don't have a law
degree you can't on the law firm right
so I was like okay cool later on I found
out that you can actually own 49 uh in
Most states I believe this would be true
Utah Arizona and Texas well you can own
49 of an accounting firm okay almost
every state I believe and now there are
a couple of these uh states that are
saying well wait a second maybe we
actually do you want non-lawyers to own
some of these law firms and so like
things are shifting because I think
people are starting to realize that wait
a second it may not actually make sense
to have only lawyers own these
businesses like they may just have a
different DNA they may have a different
skill set different interests whatever
so as I kind of got further further into
this and then you start realizing like
wait a minute the entrepreneurs I'm not
some genius they've been thinking about
this for decades they start tax advisory
companies they start you know 1031
exchange or marketing for like all these
things in and around the services that
say look if the regulation won't let me
actually own the law firm there's 10
other businesses I can own that are
right around it right and so what's
fascinating to me about this those I've
gone and talked to a bunch of these
people I'm like you guys should do this
you should do this whatever it's not in
their DNA it's just not how they think
like if you want to be an accountant
especially at a big uh accounting firm
you're taking zero risk your whole job
is around killing risk right and
mitigating that risk when someone's like
hey jump off this Cliff you're like no
dude hell no I'm not jumping off
including if you literally give me a
ladder a parachute a rope 200 Grand a
year for the next two years no yeah
because that's risk and I've trained my
entire life to kill risks I think that's
like one big piece but the other thing
is uh and some people get me I want to
say this but like
if they leave those jobs and they want
to go start companies major red flag
right now there are some people who are
very successful uh entrepreneurs a lot
of people actually they Pay Pal mafia
they got law degrees but they didn't
practice law fertility running around
here in Miami yes and so when you think
about that it's like they had the the
mental Frameworks the thinking education
that you learn in law school all of that
from law school but they didn't go and
bed themselves for 10 years in a law
firm and so again it's not to say
lawyers are bad or lawyers are good or
anything it's just like sometimes you
actually need the operator to have a
very specific skill set and a DNA that's
hard for people to wrap their heads
around unless they've talked to a ton of
these people right which you have yep
when you think about underwriting The
Operators that's on the way in how do
you know when to pull a plug if it's the
wrong person look I haven't had to do
that yet okay
um everybody everybody thinks I got this
I know I'll have to I know I will any of
the ones you have right now no don't say
who it is but let's scare some of them
maybe uh maybe Ari Kasich Mel has gotta
go no she's gonna fire you
Nick you're out of here no I think one
of the things that people don't realize
when they're sitting here talking to me
and you and they think about business
and they think about entrepreneurship
and they hear me talk about my companies
they think that we all have it all
figured out they think that we all have
Sops and everybody comes into work and
they do their job
and it just happens
business is messy and it's chaos
so many people listening to this would
be very very surprised if they knew the
big companies in their town the big
companies and their big cities nearby
big corporations that are trading on New
York you know Stock Exchange that are
total chaos on the inside
you know what I'm talking about I'm
talking about companies where it's fires
all over the place they have a few
producers in each division that are
holding the whole company together like
like duct tape and it's chaos
that is a very very common occurrence
inside of business so if you don't and
may be necessary for a business to be
successful
I think when they get to a certain size
it's it's it's a testament to two things
number one it's required being
comfortable in uncomfortable situations
is absolutely required an operator has
to have it number two is that these
businesses aren't as good as you think
they are you these managers aren't as
good as they think they are there's
people who are very good at certain
types of businesses that would look
inside under the hood of some of my
companies and been like damn Nick is an
idiot yes he's got these people doing
that he's got no system connecting he's
letting Revenue slip away over here his
leads aren't nurtured the right way over
here they would look at my company and
they would be able to give me an
education on it hire a consultant and
they'll tell you that you're dumb that's
exactly what they do yes but what people
don't understand is that all businesses
that way and as an entrepreneur you have
to thrive under those chaotic
environments you have to thrive under
that unstructured uncomfortable and you
have to get comfortable being
uncomfortable so these operators that
I'm finding I'm finding folks who okay
the world is have you seen that little
meme of the dog sitting in the Flaming
house
that is what running an agency and
building an agency is like and other and
many other types of small businesses why
build agencies I I don't want to say who
it is but I asked someone before uh
before you came in here I was like what
questions do you want to hear from them
somebody that we know and they were like
why does he keep building the agencies
why doesn't he build one big company get
some cash flow from it but build tons
and tons of equity value why not do that
you're trying to think right now no
because because people tell me that I
can't and I have an ego
like I'll just say like people tell me
that I can't do all these things and
also start companies are we gonna be
late for dinner
no
I was just checking to make sure yeah
let me look I mean make sure too
people tell me that I can't do this
stuff people tell me Nick focus on real
estate Nick you know don't get over your
skis with all these side businesses you
can't grow them all and I'm like dude I
think I can I think I can Empower these
people I think I can just do handle
distribution marketing for these
companies I think some of them will
still get very big I know I'm going to
learn a lot and I'm uncomfortable I'm
having a ton of fun
and if one or two hit then yeah I'll get
to keep piling on but I'm I'm kind of a
why would I put all my eggs in one
basket when a business needs two or
three years to mature anyway so Sam Parr
asked me this on my first million uh
we've already promoted them too much so
no one go listen
um but I I saw literally his eyes he was
like oh wait actually Pop might not be a
complete [__] when he asked me he was
like why are you doing so many different
things and I was like no I'm just
providing capital and distribution over
and over and over again I feel like
you're doing a very similar thing in
terms of helping to jump start these
businesses but is the long-term goal
like you're not involved really The
Playbook is the same I'm not I'm not
allowed to have a company email address
okay no direct reports except for the
one operator to come to me if he feels
like crying and needs to pick me up or
he needs advice on something okay I'm
coaching I'm helping where I can and
obviously I'm a tinkerer I'm love
getting involved in the businesses but
I'm I'm enabling talented people there
are people who are really really really
good at what they do and I'm just giving
them the fuel and the education helping
them go forward and providing the
distribution and providing capital
and it's really fun when you can do that
and after my first million episode that
I was on a bunch of people reached out
to me who were Killers they're killer
operators like Nick I want to start
companies Nick I want to start companies
I started talking to this guy from Cape
Town South Africa 26 year old he's
building A Little Agency had about you
know three or four grand a month of
Revenue and he's a badass he's like Nick
I want to start a company I was like
what kind of companies like a systems
company like I want to come in and I
want to set up a company from the ground
up with the right emails go to the right
places we got the domains all set up
we're building the back end of the
website where you know how does the CRM
link you know what's happening
automatically in the back end and I'm
like damn this guy's a badass and we
start talking we start talking about
potentially an SEO company he worked at
a firm for a long time knows it well
eventually I was like dude just come and
work for me
just come into my company I'll pay you a
monthly stipend and I want to see what
you can do over the next 12 months and
he's and he wrote writes me long emails
like Nick I'm going to accept your offer
and frankly I want to be you know I
don't just want to be a you know a
member of your holding company I want to
be running your holding company
and I'm like all right I'll give you
that chance
see what happens well could he mess up
well right now like he's gonna have bank
account access no well he's got a credit
card with a limit
um and again what what if he drains one
of these twenty thousand dollar bank
accounts
um no I I uh maybe I trust him to a
fault but I'm also not going to let him
totally screw me it's interesting I want
to hear your thoughts on this a lot of
well-known influencers talk about how
they were screwed a lot and how they've
always like been robbed or messed with
loser mentality something has has
happened like they've just been wronged
and they talk a lot about how they've
been wronged by so many people
most of the successful folks that I know
I asked him I was like dude have you
ever been screwed have you ever been
just totally somebody [__] told you
they're gonna do something you put money
in and the money was gone and they they
just disappeared and maybe in the crypto
space yeah that happens but have you
ever been like totally screwed over by
somebody I think that there's been
situations other people look at and be
like I cannot believe that you dealt
with that like crazy crazy [__] right
where there's somebody who uh here's a
great one there's somebody that uh has
become well known in uh the business
world who uh myself and a partner were
the First Investors in this business we
invested via a convertible note and
basically he waited the business
exploded exploded and then he came back
to us and said I'm not converting the
debt into equity and I'm not paying back
the debt good luck
okay that's that's right this is getting
screwed but I didn't think of it as
being screwed you know what I took away
from it I'll [__] never sign another
document that said that doesn't have an
auto conversion right and so like guess
what we were able to uh kind of amicably
figure it out right we we whatever we
got a decent return given how long we
were invested whatever but like
technically he was allowed to do that by
the documents 100 okay guess what guess
whose fault that was that was my fault
yeah I signed the paper yeah right like
it was a little it was a Learning lesson
I could name like 10 different
situations like that where like if you
go into that like like there are people
who be like I'm offended right like
you're you're strong to me yes I always
look at it as like dude that's a
Learning lesson so I have this whole
thing uh my wife and I always talk about
like it's practice anything that goes
wrong it's practice right and it's like
because the thing that you're learning
today is actually going to look like
practice to the big thing you're going
to do in the future what's the big thing
I don't [__] know when is the big
thing coming I don't [__] know but I
do know what is that when the big thing
comes it's going to be all these little
lessons we learned along the way and so
I do think like when you said you know
people are her screaming like loser
mentality because literally you go
around all day long being like that
person screaming that person screwed me
that person me right and so it's the
same thing I have like this like tip
rule anytime you're at a restaurant
whenever you look at the bill whatever
you think that the tip should be at a
dollar one dollar yeah right the average
you know meal that you go to which is
the average meal you go to like let's
just say that you're like okay it's 50
bucks it should be uh uh 20 you know 20
bucks
um or I'm sorry ten dollars right add
one dollar now it's 11. guess what that
person's like oh dude that was nice and
I always say the same thing it's like
they it means more to them than it does
to me yeah right and now you extrapolate
it out if the Bill's bigger or whatever
but like the same mentality of just like
if you're constantly going around like
trying to pick up pennies
you miss all the [__] value same
thing with the way you interact with
people it's like you're like oh man that
passive aggressive email [__] this
person right like dude yes it's business
like people said all kinds of crazy [__]
right people are very emotional I mean
yes but if you just look at it as like
you see it for what it is like that's
fine and so the other thing is um when
you deal with people sometimes you have
to realize like uh Plano very much uh
sometimes look at it and be like I don't
want to like be around that person
because of ABC whatever right and only
the same person might be like look I I
understand exactly who that person is I
know what I'm gonna get yeah I know
exactly the pros the cons the risks you
know all this stuff if I see them for
who they are that's fine I guess they'll
learn something from them I can still
you know do stuff with them whatever but
like you just kind of have to be like
Eyes Wide Open try to be as real as
possible and if you then go through life
and every time something bad happens
you're like what's the lesson in it
becomes a lot different so a great
example is uh when I told you that one
employee or potential employee backed
out yep
we called a couple of other employees in
the business said hey we're hiring this
person whatever so my partner in that
business as it was happening I literally
we were texting back and forth what are
the lessons and so now so every time
anything bad happens I just immediately
think what are the lessons that I can
learn from this situation and I write
them down and so you just build this
almost like internal you know kind of
book of lessons
again does that make me better than
anyone else no it just makes me like
hopefully have one less potential
mistake I'll make in the future so it's
like when I hear people say like I'm
screwed I'm just like yo that's a loser
mentality and somehow in society like
you're not supposed to say that [__]
anymore but like no you're a [__]
loser you didn't get screwed you
probably contributed just as much yeah
and people like no they stole from me
I'm like well you're the [__] who gave
them access to Steel right if you leave
your shop open and somebody comes in and
steals [__] is that their fault or your
fault like yeah you could argue that
they shouldn't do that okay fine that's
society has agreed on that but like lock
the door
I don't know like is that like crazy to
think that way
yeah oh you look like you disagree no I
agree with you 100 I just worry that I'm
gonna eat these words because what goes
on YouTube let's go no I mean I may get
[__] screwed at some point yeah and
I'll and it'll be my fault it just
hasn't happened yet yeah so maybe I am
unnecessarily trusting or maybe it's
that I don't give people access to my
bank accounts so the bank account stuff
is like super simple right but I also
think there's this element of
um
all of these like critical bad
situations they all happen on the
fringes right it's never like uh hey I
gave money to Nick and Nick then uh said
that he was going to do X and he did
something different if you if you get
the big things right in business and
your core and your foundation is solid
yeah all the stuff that happens is not
that critical like you're saying it's on
it's on the edges 100 and the other
thing too I think a lot of people uh
naturally jump to is like uh hey this
situation that doesn't look great is
coming right and what they want to do is
they're like how do we bring as much
Firepower as possible let's Sue let's do
this let's do this and what I've learned
over time it's just like dude it's
literally never worth the fight right
and so in those situations there's
always some way to solve the problem and
if it looks like it's not solvable then
there's something that you're missing in
the equation and so like when you take
that mentality of just like you are a
problem solver solve the problem I found
that you usually can find some way to to
kind of get out of these situations it's
community communication too because you
can see this stuff coming people don't
want to admit it but anytime a business
is failing it's a slow train wreck
especially in real estate because it
happens really slow you can see all
these problems coming you can see the
problems with People Brewing you can see
when people are upset you can read them
you can you can get a feel for this
stuff you just got to have those
uncomfortable conversations right away
and people aren't willing to do it
people don't want to have those hard
uncomfortable conversations all right
last thing I want to talk about is uh
the way that you interact not with the
operators but with other people in the
businesses do you tell them good job
oh yeah I'm I am I am a big complimenter
yeah okay I I uh
I will definitely provide harsh feedback
but never in a disrespectful way never
in public
um
one of my operators wants to go start a
side business on on top of one I'm like
dude you haven't proven to me that you
can run this business so like we got to
have this hard conversation now that
okay probably not yet
but
yeah a lot of compliments man a lot of
compliments so how do you feel about
this I think it's the number one
is one of the top issues that people
struggle with when they get in this
situation because there's an element of
like I'm trying to motivate these people
I'm trying to you know keep them focused
and all this kind of stuff versus when
there's too many compliments right
people sort of kind of believe their own
[__] and so like there is this very
delicate balance and I don't think that
there's a perfect science to it but the
people who get it right are way more
successful than the people who aren't I
can just see and feel who's really
laying it on the line for my companies I
can see the people the employees because
I'm tinkering I'm looking at all the
reports I can see what Engineers are
doing what and I know who's really
busting their ass to to make the company
better and sending them an email says
hey I know how much you're working like
keep it up thank you that's that goes
such a long way bosses don't do that
which is which is insane to me what
reports do you get is it daily weekly
monthly I like I'll go out for beers on
Friday night and my wife will come home
and flip on Netflix I'll go to my
computer and look at every single self
storage facility at how many move-ins we
have that month at what prices you know
how many people are moving out but
that's real-time reports that's real
time yeah okay what about the other
business Ari Costa I look at leads
because my job is distribution so I'm
looking at how many leads came in how
many properties do they have I'm looking
at sales reports so this is more like
you're looking at like dashboards you
guys have not necessarily like
somebody's compiling a report to send
you every week or anything yeah your
table dashboards yeah yeah okay and do
you ever change your behavior
I ask hard questions that's what I do
like they get one compliment for every
five hard questions I'm gonna say hey uh
here's a potential problem Brewing what
are we doing to think about this and it
drives them nuts but they're always
really good questions and we always have
some takeaways not always like okay
maybe we should wait this out I'm the
kind of guy who imagine a company is a
is a globe I'm the kind of guy who like
just like a basketball you keep it
spinning keep it rolling forward I'm the
kind of guy who jerks it so I kind of
I've learned over the years that I can't
just come in and wreck should turn [__]
over and make it I want it all to happen
right away and [__] happens really fast
in my companies but I also know that I
can't my employees are all going to quit
and leave if I'm up there up their ass
every day we have uh somebody works for
one of our businesses that recently was
basically telling me like uh hey I have
a lot of things like they were
distracted right and so uh I kind of
took a leap it was one of the first time
I'd done it but I said listen here's
what I want you to do every single day I
want you to wake up and I want you to
literally when you wake up get on your
computer and you send me what are your
priorities for the day and I'll agree
right and uh I recently had a one-on-one
I bet you didn't even have to really
respond because him thinking through
that straightened it right out yeah and
and so like I was like you know at first
there's gonna be five or ten things and
maybe we agree on 20 or 30 percent right
but over time like we'll learn each
other and we'll eventually get to 100
alignment every single day and I
recently had a one-on-one with this
person and they told me uh yeah it's
crazy I get so much more done and uh I'm
so much more efficient and I was like
what do you mean and they're like well
before like I didn't I wasn't clear on
the priorities so like I had all this
extra time and like the work expanded to
fit the time right and so now I'm like
wait a minute maybe actually the driving
Factor isn't you know uh anything more
so than just like the more you put on
their plate you can drive the efficiency
and actually I think the best people
that's what they want because I feel
like they're getting a lot of wins in
the day right and so you go from like I
got one thing done every two days to
like maybe get three things done today
it builds momentum right kind of where
we start the conversation so you're
ahead of me in this game you've been at
it for longer your reach is bigger your
distribution is more you've made a lot
of Investments only for now
what blind spots do you see like you
talking to me you're getting a look into
my mind for an hour now what do you
think
should be something I'm more aware of
that maybe I'm not as focused as I
should be on or something that you could
see messing all this up and if you're
watching this comment and let me know
email me Nick sweatystarup.com if you've
just got to look in my mind for an hour
there's three areas that everyone [__]
up uh one
um it's all the personal reputation
stuff like your personal reputation will
get destroyed over time for things that
you don't even do right and what I mean
by that is like the percentage of people
in your audience let's say one percent
are haters well at least be one person
then it was ten there was a hundred then
it was whatever they're the loudest
right and so what will end up happening
is they will start to
um kind of like lionize or really go
after things that you do that you don't
think are a big deal and do they sway
those folks who aren't necessarily
they're just the loudest right and so
like that that ends up happening and so
like you got to get really really
comfortable just be like I literally
don't give a [__] what do you guys think
right so I think that happens to
everyone and I see like there's some
people who came out of nowhere
um I'll use Andrea cooperman as an
example I love his content right he's
done a fantastic job you're like how
could anyone ever get mad at that guy
yeah recently I saw he's like in the
comments he's having to respond to
people and stuff right and it's like
once you cross that line into like okay
now now I'm in The Fray you just can't
win right because somebody's always
gonna have a problem whatever so like in
some weird way like the more authentic
you are the more people expect you to
respond and so like you gotta like kind
of figure that out I don't know what the
solution is but I think that's always a
huge risk for people I never felt good
after getting in those comments you're
right nothing good ever happened
but like you have part of the audience
because you were authentic you responded
to comments and like you know what I
mean so it's like that's like so I think
that's like a huge thing no one really
talks about the second thing is uh
uh your natural reaction will be to do
more and more and more and there is some
equilibrium one company is probably not
the right answer a hundred companies is
not the right answer where is that
balance and like what people don't like
to admit is like on Monday it may be
five companies on Wednesday could be ten
right and like it depends on what else
you have going on in your life like you
know uh cash flow
um about pulling an operator even
shutting down a company because you yeah
I'm gonna have to do that at some point
you're gonna have to do it but also uh
it's easy like some of these questions
are connected and like okay cool we're
you and I are going to start a business
in six months if we're not doing a
hundred thousand dollars in annual
recurring Revenue then we're gonna shut
the business down great we get there
we're at 90k
all right you gotta put another 25 000
in okay if we're not at 200k we'll make
it up at the one year mark then we're
gonna shut it down
we're at 185 right or at or at 195 tough
decisions right and so like some of it's
like hey I'm a bet on myself I'm uh you
know I'm a believer I'm courageous I'm
all this stuff and where's the line
don't you cross over stupidity
this is the nitty-gritty of all this
stuff right so I think like that piece
of like starting a lot of stuff is like
fun and exciting and all that but like
when you have to start killing things
then what do you do with that person if
they're good maybe you can put them
somewhere else you know inside of the
organization if they're not good you
gotta get rid of like just again
nitty-gritty right and then the third
thing is uh self-funding versus uh
external funding if it's successful
you're an idiot not to raise tons and
tons of money and pour gas in the fire
and make it explode right in like a
positive way
but like man it's nice when you're
getting distributions and kind of all
this stuff and so like it doesn't
necessarily have to be in either or I've
seen people who have raised money and
it's like under the guise of hey we're
gonna take distributions here's the
formula or whatever but usually what
ends up happening is the self-funding
everything kind of like caps out at like
five to ten million dollars of Revenue
very few businesses like convertkit I
think uh they do like 30 million dollars
in Revenue bootstrapped right
um butcher box they do 550 to 600
million dollars a year in Revenue
bootstrapped right so you can do it but
it's still like even convertkit right if
you were to talk to Nathan like could
they be bigger with funding maybe maybe
actually would have killed them right
you can suffocate a business with
capital just as much as you can starve
it and so you start getting into likes
again like okay what am I actually
trying to accomplish here am I
optimizing for cash flow am I optimizing
for Equity if that's both is this a 10
million dollar a year uh uh Revenue
business that throws off three million
dollars of cash and like if we get there
let's not trick ourselves into thinking
there's a 100 million dollar opportunity
there's no like hey you avoid this one
pothole right I will say it's been you
talk to guys like you know Xavier and
sieva with him during Adventures I know
you see Brent be sure you see these
folks who buy companies and that's sexy
man like it's easy for me to say damn
what am I doing starting these companies
from nothing when you can go out and
raise a little bit of money buy these
businesses grow them
um yeah it's uh there's there's just so
many ways to do this stuff so many ways
to do this stuff not one of them's right
that's the hard part of all this the you
know the people I think are most scared
of kind of the world we're talking about
these private Equity guys are going to
get their faces smashed you think so 100
because guess what how are you going to
win a deal over Kim Kardashian she had a
private Equity Firm you were screwed you
were not winning yeah Mark Wahlberg is A
Better Private Equity Adventures or uh
Matt McConaughey just yeah uh Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds Matt McConaughey
uh uh Mark Wahlberg Rob dreirdack right
uh George Clooney Kim Kardashian The
Rock The Rock's a [__] billionaire
right like y'all are all laughing the
dude's got a billion so you see what
we're talking about here just
accelerating the distribution and the
name and the trust that comes along with
a personal brand whether you're an
athlete an actor or or a media
personality like us that can accelerate
entrepreneurship which we haven't seen a
lot of the Kardashians and and these
folks we're talking about now but
there's also a lot of influencers with
millions of subscribers that don't make
any money I think a lot of those people
haven't yet realized it but they will
and so it's you know early adopters
people are a little late or whatever
um but also you're going to see a rise
of entrepreneurs are like dude I don't
give a [__] about content but I can
operate let me go partner up with
somebody who's got a big content piece
if you're listening together you have a
couple guys no yeah you're right I mean
the operations is the hard part and
finding these operators is the tough
part
um the distribution is the stuff that
comes natural to you and I the
nitty-gritty of running these companies
is the hard uncomfortable work yeah and
so if you asked me like
in the investing world I think there are
four themes they're maybe some more but
like four themes I think are really
really big themes over the next you know
20 years the first is there's going to
be a complete debasement of Fiat
currencies around the world doesn't mean
hyperinflation or anything like that it
just means that there's going to be
alternative currencies Bitcoin
specifically the second thing is that
there's going to be a rise of automation
Bitcoin kind of falls under that but
also all the artificial intelligence and
not because people are gonna go build AI
companies is because they're just going
to automate things inside of their
company I have been pitched 500
different projects and features and all
this nonsense the things where I see the
most value occurring right now are
people just using the technology inside
their companies to go faster so similar
to the gas powered lawnmower
revolutionizing lawn care companies just
made them more efficient correct
powerful and better yeah so like okay
how do I use this to write my blog posts
behind the mower correct so then the
third thing uh is this idea of like go
find the customers first and then build
the businesses so whether that is
actually private Equity type backed with
funds Etc whether it's individuals or
whatever just like finding the customers
first is now possible and then you can
go build a product and so like there's a
whole bunch of Technologies and nuances
that have changed that allow that to
happen but then the fourth one is I
actually think a lot of people are just
gonna say dude I don't need the job that
I had but I don't actually want to be
like a true operator that has like a
whole company with people that report to
me yeah do you know how many single
employee uh multi-millionaires are gonna
get created in the next 20 years it is
going to be insane I mean we know
several of them already but yeah a ton I
agree with that you're gonna sit in
front of your little portal into the
[__] internet with these tools The
Leverage is exploding yeah and so like
now you're gonna be a single person and
you're gonna make millions of dollars a
year using these tools living wherever
you want yeah but you just gotta like
figure out what the angle is and so like
I don't even know if we could sit and
identify like oh here's 10 different
ideas of like how to do that yet but
there are example after example after
example and I look at like the line of
pride progress it is not linear it is
exponential in terms of how many people
are figuring this out and so like
everyone's like I want to go build the
next you know super sexy app or whatever
sure maybe you can do that but guess
what is actually going to be more likely
so you're going to figure out some way
to take your uh Consulting skills you're
going to put up a landing page right
people are going to hit you up and
you're going to charge them a reasonable
rate and you're going to do it from
anywhere in the world behind your
computer and you're going to make 350
000 you're gonna do that for a decade
and you're literally gonna go flex at
your kid's school and be like I'm rich
yeah right and you guys are all going to
an office and so like as that theme
plays out you then can see how easily
how like these four themes start to
converge too right and so you have like
this whole automation thing you have uh
um kind of the solo you know uh folks
and then you're also going to have the
audience
like guess what you're doing you have
the audience you start out as an
individual right but you're like pushing
down and delegating and then you're
building all these automated systems
like that's the future of the world yeah
I love it man where can we send people
to find you
I write a newsletter every week that
I've been putting a lot of time into all
right what's it called it's called Nick
Huber's newsletter it says
sweatystartup.com and you can sign up
for it
sweatystartup.com yeah I'm going to
start a little business brokerage
company that I'm excited about and
through nickuber.com where we're going
to invest in one company a year partner
with one or two companies a year and
broker three or four companies a year
that are you know in the audience buy
box I'm excited about that but yeah man
Twitter at sweaty startup send me a DM
my DMs are open I read most of them
don't respond to most of them
thank you
but uh I'm gonna send Nick a DM after
this we'll see if your response all
right thank you for doing this very very
appreciative for having me man this is
this is amazing I just got a master
class this is amazing all right we'll do
it again